lo fai vedere così che vale sei tu che
sei solo la tua tv lasciami stare ma tra
poco inizia tentation highland vip una
volta mentre per tenere anche una
puntata farà più niente di tutto quel
trash no scommetto che per colpa di
quello stronzo di netflix è per colpa so
che non mi fa più vedere vero metrics ma
lasciami stare tu sei pazzo pazzo io a
differenza sua
sono gratis gratis hai capito tornerai
da me
ma chissà come questo netflix
vediamo se è così bello come dicono
ciao sono netflix in cima e comunque non
sono meglio sono migliore
e a quel punto nera b chiama professore
gli dice il professore sono l'aerobica
da questo momento sono al comando come
lasciano il mater e allora quando
l'indice sono pablo emilio escobar
gaviria lato blog
e a quel punto blair lo guarda dritto
negli occhi e gli dice tre parole sette
lettere mille e solo tu e lui il miele
bettoni per saperlo di riguardare il
prossimo episodio che inizia tra 5 ma
sono le tre di notte domani mi devo
svegliare presto questa serate volata se
vuoi possiamo continuare a letto beh non
penso sia una buona idea è stato
fantastico
e ancora ma subito prossimo episodio tra
56 la serata credo che sia andata bene
però non è ancora scritto né sante non
so forse non riscriverlo mari sia
indossando sì sì scusami eh che ieri
sera ha fatto un po tardi e con chi
adesso dimmi tutto si chiama netflix è
praticamente per oggi è stata una serata
cioè pazzesco con tutto è stata fino
alle 6 del mattino
eri con lui però mi fai schifo sono
sempre stato per te e tu e tu mi fai
questo
grazie meno male che ci sei tu andiamo a
casa baby
allora del roni che si avvicina sharing
e libici volevi il fuoco scusa ieri il
bombshell e le specialità e mi piace
tantissimo
devo andare alle mie amiche mi aspetta
seconda stagione di disponibile
sì lo so lo so però mi stanno aspettando
si stasera va contro spooner asse forse
dovreste restare a casa e guardarla
adesso bel massimo mi tappo le orecchie
non possono andare dai mi sto aspettando
oppure sei stanca è già tardi forse una
serata perfetta per un patinato di sé in
cina forse hai ragione però allora
domani esco mai
e adesso cosa c'è stavo per cenare due
vedove di lì l'ho già visto dai hosting
ho già visto pure quello ho già visto
tutte le tue seri e infine proposto
fanno veramente schifo sono un sacco di
cose che deve ancora vedere documentario
sulle orc e quello sui macachi nel film
delle winx fa più fatica ma ti rendi
conto che cosa otto anni la verità è che
mi sono stancata diventate basta non ti
sopporto più
parliamo di per favore parliamone
perfetto io sono stanca sono state di
saltare i pasti per colpa tua
sono stanca di non riuscire a passare
nemmeno un esame per tu con te nei
paraggi non si riesce a studiare e
soprattutto sono stata di passare notti
terre a guardare le tue serie ma come
aveva guardare ci sono state in otto in
cui lo so nemmeno riuscita a scender né
una colpa mia se completatelo così
grande e poi comunque ti consiglio
sempre film e serie tv in base a quello
che hai guardato certo infatti ha finito
di guardare i narcos e sai cosa mi
consigliate è prove rose dico io e
qualità indici che c'è un collegamento
perchè giuro che ti ammazzo ho deciso
chi ha di meno per sempre alla mia vita
ma smettila di crash rai ma a noi
amo ciao settima stasera cosa fai perché
avevo pensato no possiamo fare una
seratina per vecchi tempi io te e il
nostro amico gen tonica ma mi piacerebbe
un sacco però stasera credo di avere un
qualche linea di febbre
facciamo meglio che stia a casa e niente
allora facciamo prossima volta sì sì
certo assolutamente e chiami tu allora
domani ti chiamo io promesso
ciao ciao ciao allora dovremmo rimasti
dopo appunto nairobi chiama professore e
gli diceva professore sono mai raleigh
in questo momento sono io a comano
comincia il matriarcato
[Musica]